Communities to practice are unique
learning and doing environments.
They were detailed in great
book from 1991 called,
Legitimate Peripheral Participation.
And it basically suggests
that novices and
experts work together in
certain environments.
And the novices actually learn
from the experts while the experts
are doing some task.
And over time, the novices take
a little bit of responsibility and
then a little bit more.
And learn how to contribute to that
environment while also contributing to
that environment.
So for an example that's used in that
book is the example of midwives.
So when a midwife is first
being trained in certain areas,
the first thing she goes through is just
being in the room during childbirth.
She experiences the different things
that the experienced midwives
are saying and doing and
just kind of gets a feel for it.
And then over time, she takes on
a couple responsibilities, and
a couple more, and learns, and
learns a little bit more each day.
And eventually is an expert herself,
and can start training her own novices.
It's a very apprenticeship
driven approach.
And that book they suggested, this is
really one of the best ways to learn.
because your learning right
in the authentic context,
where you'll ultimately
contribute to what you learned.
But it presents a lot of
difficulties for classroom learning,
because classrooms
are completely absent of this.
You very rarely have classrooms
where you really are doing what you
are learning to do.
You're learning in place to the idea of
being that you're going to go out into
the world and then do it in a job or
do it in a career.
But in the classroom you're not actually
contributing, but this learning theory
suggests that that's the opposite
of a great way to learn.
So the question is,
can we create these kind of
environments where this is simulated,
where students are experiencing what
it would be like to contribute a little
more over time to this enterprise
that they're trying to learn.
Technology may be able
to help us with this,
because with technology we can
create these kinds of similations.
We can simulate, whatever career
the students are going to go into and
simulate giving them some of these
responsibilities while AI agents or
the simulation itself
takes care of the rest.
So we'll talk about the value
of this educational approach,
as well as how we can use technology
to really bring it to life.